ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
wer nicht ganz still wird wenn sich über
ihm ein klarer sternenhimmel spannt der
gegner ein bisschen auf den wecker und
wer behauptet ist beschäftige ihn nicht
was sie uns die größe und das alter des
universums überhaupt nicht vorstellen
können irritiert mich eigentlich gibt es
doch kaum etwas eher furchterregendes
aus der bestand der himmel über uns wie
immanuel kant 1 sagte deshalb habe ich
mir heute beim uhr ins studio geholt um
mit ihm auf eine philosophische odyssee
zu gehen durch das universum der
ausdruck sich herzlich willkommen
solche zubehör herr moore berührt sie
der sternenhimmel hat nicht noch wenn
sie in einer sternklaren nacht über sich
schauen absolut es ist atemberaubend
draußen zu stehen irgendwo hoch oben
weit weg von den stadt lichtern
das gibt einem das gefühl von ehrfurcht
dann wird mir jedes mal bewusst weshalb
ich astrophysik studiert habe aber im
moment als professor an der universität
zürich aus austro physiker sitzen sie ja
eigentlich nicht vor dem sternenhimmel
sondern mehr vor irgendwelchen riesigen
bildschirmen wo sie den anfang des
universums simulieren
sehen sie da hinter den vorne noch
wirklich die sterne oder ist das einfach
pure mathematik
das stimmt ich habe viel zeit am
bildschirm verbracht und auf zahlen und
e-mails gstaad
ich hätte lieber wieder die sterne
beobachtet deshalb habe ich mir letztes
jahr ein wirklich gutes teleskop gekauft
ich nehme es gerne mit in die berge
zurzeit gebe ich an der universität
zürich einen kurs in astrofotografie so
können die studenten hinausgehen und die
sterne genießen mit dem teleskop objekte
beobachten
es war wunderschön zu den anfängen
zurück zu kehren und das universum
wieder mit meinem auge zu betrachten und
habe ich das gefühl dass teilen sie mit
ihren studenten also sind die meisten
die astrophysiker sind auch wirklich
nach wie vor fasziniert von den sternen
oder gibt es auch die puren sagen wir
mathematiker unter den astrophysikern
die gar nicht so sehr die schönheit des
alles bewundern
ich denke viele studenten haben
ihr studium der astrophysik begonnen
weil sie die sterne beobachtet und ein
interesse entwickelt haben für das was
da draußen ist und wenn sie dann den
bachelor machen oder doktor ihren dann
schlagen sie sich nur noch mit
gleichungen und computern herum
sie haben kaum mehr die möglichkeit
hinauszugehen und den nachthimmel zu
würdigen also gehe ich hin aus wann
immer ich kann
geben sie mir auch einen tipp wo in der
schweiz kann ich denn den schönsten
sternenhimmel sie überall außerhalb der
städte weit weg von den stadt lichtern
je höher desto besser ich gehe gerne
nach davos
dort haben wir eine kleine wohnung einen
zufluchtsort in den bergen wo wir
wandern gehen und uns die sterne ansehen
das universum ist ja riesen riesengroß
allein die dimensionen erschüttern mich
ehrlich gesagt weil ich mir das
überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann
wir haben hier ein paar bilder
mitgebracht hier kann ich mich gerade
noch aus ich kann das noch heraus wählt
also uns unsere erde erkennen und jetzt
verliere ich nicht bereits können sie
mir ein tipp geben wo sind wir hier
gerade wir reisen gerade sehr schnell
durch das sonnensystem
diese grünen kreise das sind die
umlaufbahnen der planeten
jetzt verlassen wir den interstellaren
raum hier bewegen wir uns schneller als
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit wir verlassen
gerade unser kleines bewohnbares
sonnensystem
wir reisen durch den interstellaren raum
durch unsere eigene galaxie im
hintergrund sehen wir die milchstraße
diese drehende scheibe der sterne
das ist unsere galaxie wir sind unerhört
schnell unterwegs und verlassen gerade
die milchstraße und hier der
intergalaktischen raum die lehre
zwischen den galaxien
doch diese kleinen grünen punkte stellen
die positionen der galaxien da auch
unsere die mit unzähligen sternen
gefüllt sind und jetzt reisen wir durch
das universum zwischen den uns bekannten
galaxien
es gibt keinen eigentlichen kern
wir reisen durch unser eigenes universum
jetzt gehen wir zurück zur erde
dieses universum im moment des
expandiert ja weiß aber wie groß ist das
im moment diese frage wird häufig
gestellt den umfang des kosmos des
universums zu beschreiben ist extrem
schwierig ich kann es nicht
mein verstand ist nicht an die riesigen
zahlen und größen in unserem universum
gewohnt wie erfassen mit unseren augen
zb eine menge von ein paar tausend
menschen
wir können ein paar kilometer weit sehen
vielleicht haben sie eine million dollar
auf dem bankkonto die sehen sie zwar nie
doch eine million ist noch erfassbar
aber wir sind es nicht gewohnt eine
milliarde zu sehen wir haben keine
vorstellung von solchen mengen ich kann
versuchen die größe des universums zu
veranschaulichen sie wollten gerne
zucker haben um das zu zeigen wir haben
im zucker mitgebracht zeigen sie mal wie
groß gut den kaffee nehme ich später ich
beginne mit dem zucker um etwas über die
größe unseres kosmos zu sagen müssen wir
die größen von objekten im maßstab
ändern
stellen wir uns vor jeder dieser
zuckerkristalle sei ein einzelner stern
das hilft uns den kosmos zu
veranschaulichen dieser schlüssel
befindet sich etwa ein kilogramm zucker
die kern habe ich vorher noch ab gezählt
das sind etwa eine million zu verkaufen
in dieser schüsse sind also etwa eine
million sterne allein unsere galaxie ist
ziemlich groß und enthält etwa 100
milliarden sterne
wir würden also etwa 10.000 solcher
schüsseln benötigen nur um die sterne in
unserer galaxie darzustellen das würde
den ganzen raum hier füllen
und das ist dann erst unsere galaxie das
ist nur eine galaxie und allein in
unserem sichtbaren universum sind da
noch viel mehr legen wir unseren einen
sternen mal hier drauf dieses zucker
körnchen hier stellt unsere sonne da im
vergleich dazu ist unsere erde nur ein
körnchen in der größe eines winzigen
bakteriums zwei zentimeter von der sonne
entfernt unser sonnensystem würde diesen
maßstab film um zum nächsten stern zu
gelangen müsste ich fünf kilometer weit
wandern und dieses zucker körnchen dort
platzieren
das wäre dann der stern alpha centauri
die distanz zwischen den zucker körnchen
welche die sterne darstellen beträgt
also rund fünf kilometer also die
nächste sonne oder der nächste stern auf
erkennt aurich 5 km zu fuß rein von den
dimensionen her ja ja und wenn wir das
jetzt ins ins ganze welt dar einstellen
wir sind jetzt immer noch sehr sehr in
ganz ganz kleinen immer noch bei uns
also wir haben jetzt gerade mal die
nachbars galaxie thematisiert wie viele
galaxien gibt es denn hier müssten den
zucker aus hunderttausend schüssel
nehmen dieser zucker würde dann
ausgebreitet und sich über den
rauminhalt bis zum mond erstrecken
dann hätten wir unsere galaxie um zur
nächsten großen galaxie zu gelangen dem
andromeda nebel würden wir in der
entfernung von ungefähr eine million
kilometer den nächsten haufen zu
platzieren und so geht das immer weiter
der weltraum ist so weitläufig dass ich
ihn auch nicht mehr mit dem zucker
darstellen kann
in unserem universum können wir etwa 100
milliarden galaxien sehen unser
sichtbares weltall hat einen durchmesser
von ungefähr 100 milliarden lichtjahren
das ist aber nur die distanz welche wir
sehen können das ist die distanz die das
licht seit dem urknall zurückgelegt hat
also seit der entstehung unseres
universums wir können nicht über diese
distanz hinaus sehen weil das licht noch
keine zeit gehabt hat zu uns zu gelangen
was jenseits dieser sichtbaren sphäre um
uns herum liegt wissen wir nicht was
jenseits der 100 milliarden lichtjahre
liegt wissen wir nicht wir wissen also
nicht wie weit das universum reicht es
könnte unendlich weit sein oder auch nur
ein wenig weiter wir wissen es nicht
und laut einstein werden wir es auch
wissen weil das meiste in einsteins
theorien über das universum also die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie auf dem
postulat basiert das information nicht
schneller als lichtgeschwindigkeit sein
kann
wir können also nie informationen
darüber erhalten was über der distanz
liegt die das licht zurückgelegt hat
deswegen ist meine frage die ich jetzt
stellen möchte wahrscheinlich die
dümmste frage überhaupt euch muss sie
trotzdem stellen was war denn oder oder
wo ist sozusagen das ende des universums
und was kommt dahinter wir können ja
keine grenze denken ohne zu denken dass
etwas jenseits der grenze liegt also was
ist hinter dem universum keine ahnung
haben wahrscheinlich geht es einfach
immer weiter mit noch viel mehr galaxien
in alle richtungen
an einem gewissen punkt kommt es wohl
ans ende ich weiß es nicht
wir können es nicht sagen ich mache die
unendlichkeit nicht ich kann mir das
unendliche universum nicht vorstellen
das ist einfach immer weiter geht in
alle ewigkeit
vielleicht gibt es ein ende des raums
und an diesem ende würde sich der raum
krümmen würde man an die grenze des
universums stoßen würde man das nicht
merken weil das licht sich krümmen und
wieder zurückkehren würde
man würde die galaxien von der anderen
richtung aussehen
dann müssten wir das nicht beschreiben
und das ist ein schwieriges konzept was
ist das nichts
jenseits dieser grenze das sind alles
die unglaublich schwierigen konzepte und
da kommt man ja eigentlich zur
philosophie und ich finde auch wenn man
einen sternenhimmel anschaut sie haben
selber gesagt dass sie das nach wie vor
berührt dann ist es nicht nur
philosophische fragen die mir durch den
kopf gehen
sondern viele menschen haben ja auch so
was wie ein religiöses gefühl wenn sie
ins all gucken
das sind religiöse gefühle die einen
dann einfach erfüllen weil es so
unglaublich schön ist aber auch so
unglaublich unfassbar
kennen sie selber solche gefühle
religiöse gefühle angesichts des blicks
ins universum gewiss erlebe ich ein
gefühl von ehrfurcht und erstaunen
ich würde das nicht unbedingt als ein
religiöses erlebnis bezeichnen
aber ich nehme die schönheit des
universums war mit seiner unglaublichen
physik mathematik den wissenschaften
deren aufeinandertreffen uns sterne und
galaxien schenken
unser universum ist ein unglaublich
kompliziert wir fangen erst an es zu
begreifen
für mich bringt die idee eines gottes
als schöpfer des universums keine neue
erkenntnis wir wissen zwar nicht wie
unser universum entstanden ist das ist
immer noch eines der großen probleme
es gibt hunderte verschiedener
religionen auf unserem planeten sie alle
haben verschiedene vorstellungen von der
entstehung des universums
das ist großartig denn die menschen sind
wirklich daran interessiert und wollen
das verstehen
darum gibt es die verschiedenen
geschichten über die entstehung des
universums gott als schöpfer ist eine
davon
aber für mich erklärt die ist nichts man
müsste dann immer noch zu erklären
versuchen woher gott kommt wir haben
herrn hitler mutschler getroffene ist
philosoph physiker und theologe und er
sagt es überrascht nicht dass gott
eigentlich für die naturwissenschaften
nicht wirklich interessant ist ja dass
die naturwissenschaften gott eigentlich
gar nicht brauchen
schauen wir uns haben was er dazu zu
sagen habt ihr den gott braucht es
überhaupt nie in der physik da kann ja
gar nicht vorkommen da ist durch die
methode schon ausgeschlossen
der ist kein mögliches objekte physik
infolgedessen kann auch seine existenz
nicht negiert werden von dort aus also
wenn ein fuß
er sagt ich brauche den gott nicht sage
ich ja ich gratuliere aber das sagt gar
nichts über seine existenz aus der
physiker braucht auch keine freiheit der
braucht keine vernunft er braucht kein
bewusstsein aber daraus kann ich doch
nicht schließen dass es kein bewusstsein
gibt aber keine freiheit lässt nun ich
würde gerne verstehen wann und wie unser
universum entstanden ist ich denke nur
die wissenschaft kann diese frage
beantworten
vielleicht könnte die wissenschaft zu
gott führen und wenn das die antwort
wäre dann wäre das so dann hätten wir
die evidenz und den beweis wenn die
wissenschaft zu einem alternativen
szenario führen würde wäre eben dass die
antwort und die beiden lösungen die
halten sich im moment die waage also
würden sie sagen dass schon möglich dass
irgendwann gott beweisen können
der beweis dieses beweises ich weiß es
nicht
es ist eines der schwierigsten probleme
mit dem wir konfrontiert sind
wir forschen allerdings erst seit ein
paar jahrhunderten wissenschaftlich
darüber in den wenigen hundert jahren
sind wir weit gekommen
wir haben gemerkt dass das universum
einen anfang hatte und dass es ein ende
haben wird
das ist ein riesiger fortschritt wir
verstehen unser universum bis eine
sekunde nach dem urknall
aber da stecken wir fest geben sie uns
nochmals 1000 jahre
dann werden wir ein paar antworten mehr
haben wir müssen ja nicht alle antworten
bereits heute haben wenn sie den urknall
erwähnen der hat ja eigentlich so zu
sagen er ist ist an die stelle gottes
getreten ein stück weit dass man hat
sich immer gefragt wie hat das alles
angefangen heute geht man eigentlich von
dieser urknall theorie aus irgendwann
hat der urknall stattgefunden
wie kam es denn zu diesem urknall
irgendwann muss ja diese unendliche
energie da gewesen sein also irgendetwas
muss die initialzündung sozusagen
gegeben haben weiß man darüber dass der
urknall ist eigentlich eine beschreibung
dessen was wir über das universum wissen
das universum hat zum zeitpunkt null
begonnen
aber wir begreifen t0 nicht das ist der
augenblick in dem es begonnen hat unsere
physik reicht nur bis zu einem bruchteil
der ersten sekunde an den urknall heran
der urknall beschreibt wie sich das
universum nach seiner entstehung bis
heute entwickelt hat ueber den aller
ersten augenblick sagt der urknall
nichts aus nur dass es eine ursprung
gegeben hat doch wir wissen nicht was
dieser ursprung wirklich ist und wie es
dazu gekommen ist eine der aufregendsten
entdeckungen des letzten jahrzehnts war
die antwort auf die frage was ist die
energie des universums
es ist eine zahl welche mittels
beobachtungen berechnet wurde nun die
durchschnittliche energie im universum
ist genau die gesamte energie unseres
universums ist 0
es gibt die energie in der ausdehnung
des raumes und die negative energie der
schwerkraft welche dagegen hält und
zurückzieht dann gibt es die schwarze
energie das ist die neu entdeckte
energie all diese energien können wir
messen die positive energie und die
negative sie neutralisieren sich und
ergeben 0
um also das universum zu erschaffen
benötigt man lediglich etwas raum und
null energie kann trennt man die null
energie in positive und negative energie
und so hat man die ausdehnung doch schon
lautet die nächste frage woher stammt
dieses stück raum wer hat diese energie
voneinander auseinandergenommen
also das ist ja wirklich so die idee des
unbewegten vegas denn die idee die die
philosophen immer schon beschäftigt hat
wer ist sozusagen derjenige der diese
initialzündung gegeben hat dann
natürlich ist es eine eigenartige der
sich vorzustellen dass jetzt ein gott
der sowas gemacht hat aber trotzdem
kriegt man doch diese frage nicht weg
oder können sie diese frage ausblenden
der kosmologe will auf diese schwierige
frage eine antwort finden wir hoffen
dass es uns eines tages gelingen wird
leider haben wir noch keine antwort
darauf
doch die idee des entworfenen universums
ist für mich ein bisschen eigenartig
besonders die vorstellungen das
universum sei einzig für den menschen
erschaffen worden
ich mag die idee von der sonderstellung
des menschen in diesem universum nicht
ich hoffe die wissenschaft werde mit der
zeit diese frage beantworten
wir müssen bloß abwarten um die antwort
zu erfahren
ich erlebe sie auch sehr positiv denken
über die wissenschaft sie denken wir
werden da immer weiter weiter
fortschritte machen
mama kriege ich fast den eindruck ich
meine ich verstehe natürlich überhaupt
nichts von dieser materie was kommen wir
mal ein bisschen vor vor als hätte man
heute unglaublich komplizierte theorien
und modelle entwickelt und zu erklären
was passiert ist aber eigentlich
verstehen wir diese modelle selber gar
nicht mehr so richtig es ist pure
mathematik aber so richtig mit unserem
empfinden und unseren intuition kann mir
es nicht mehr in einklang bringen kann
am anfang auch gesagt allein die zahlen
sind so groß wir können sie uns nicht
vorstellen geht es ein bisschen uns ein
bisschen sowie immanuel kant das mal
beschrieben habe dass wir von fragen
belästigt werden die uns die vernunft
auf gegeben habt aber wir haben keine
vernunft die sie lösen kann wenn man
könnte so darüber denken
die fragen die wir beantwortet haben
wollen sind die großen fragen wie warum
sind wir hier wohin gehen wir
bei diesen fragen vermag die
wissenschaft nur an der oberfläche zu
kratzen
was wir wissen und was wir nicht wissen
steht in grossen ungleichgewicht wir
wissen nur ganz wenig von dem was es zu
wissen gibt
ob wir all diese fragen beantworten
können weiß ich nicht aus
pessimistischer sicht kann ich all' das
erklären was wir nicht wissen wir wissen
nicht was raum ist der raum zwischen mir
und ihnen wir wissen nicht wirklich was
zeit ist was teilchen sind wir wissen
nicht was kräfte sind was schwerkraft
ist
wir haben keine ahnung was vor sich geht
wir können es zwar mit einer formel
beschreiben aber das ist unbefriedigend
ich will mit ganzer wahrnehmung erfassen
was uns am boden unseres planeten hält
und das macht mich unzufrieden
es gibt unzählige dinge die wir nicht
verstehen
zb die ladung des elektrons wäre dieses
nur leicht anders dann gäbe es keine
sterne und kein leben
wieso ist das universum so fein
abgestimmt wunderbare fragen aber wie
ich schon gesagt habe
leider hat die wissenschaft erst damit
begonnen diese fragen zu beantworten
franken zurück weil sie sagen die dazu
wissenschaften sind dass sie mit dem sie
sich beschäftigen und die anderen fragen
da wissen die einfach nicht lassen sie
mich doch noch einmal auf die religion
zurückkommen ich habe dieses buch mit
großem interesse gelesen von rotor
kennen ist schon zwei jahre auf religion
ohne gott und er beschäftigt sich damit
auch darin auch mit einsteigen
weinstein hat er von sich gesagt er sei
eigentlich ein tiefgläubiger mensch aber
es ist ein glaube ohne religion oder
seine rolle religion ohne job das ist
kein tennis und tork entschlüsselt das
sehr schön auf er sagt eigentlich haben
die gläubigen menschen meistens zwei
ideen im kopf einerseits eine
wissenschafts idee eine theorie darüber
wie die welt entstanden ist und
versetzen sie gott hin und eine idee
darüber dass dieses universum und unsere
welt irgend ein wertvolles sinnhaftes
geordnetes ganzes ist um nicht einfach
ein teilchen haufen nicht einfach ein
chaos und wolken sagt jemand wie ein
stein und auch jemand wie er selber wird
nicht an einen gott glauben der die erde
erschaffen habt aber man hätte doch
dieses gefühl und diesen eindruck wenn
man durch den grand canyon waren wird
oder wenn man den sternenhimmel
betrachtet oder wenn man in die augen
eines neugeborenen blickt dass da
einfach mehr sein muss und das ist nicht
einfach nur ein teilchen auf listen wir
irgend eine bedeutungslose eintagsfliege
können sie mit dieser art von religion
etwas anfangen
ich denke dass unsere gehirne oftmals
glauben müssen dass da mehr ist
die neurowissenschaften werfen
neuerdings ein nicht darauf es ist ja
gut wenn sie an mehr glauben wollen als
man wahrnehmen kann
ein engel an drachen an feen oder an
gott das ist großartig
glauben sie was immer sie wollen wenn es
sie glücklich macht aber mir hilft das
keineswegs
und auch der wissenschaft hilft der
glaube nicht dass universum zu verstehen
und deshalb muss man trennen zwischen
staat und religion oder zwischen
wissenschaft und religion glauben sie
was immer sie wollen das kann ich gut
akzeptieren
es gibt dann ein problem wenn sie ihre
religiösen ansichten anderen auferlegen
wollen und das ist noch mal ein anderes
thema die ganze missionierung von von
ungläubigen menschen
ich glaube es ging mir viel mehr darum
was ist denn die alternative die
alternative ist doch zu sagen dass alles
diese schönheit der grand canyon ein
neugeborenes kind wir das ist alles
einfach das ergebnis eines unfalls die
schönheit liegt im auge des betrachters
die neurowissenschaften wollen uns
aufzeigen wie unser hirn mit der zeit
lernt dass sich unser bewusstsein mit
der zeit verändert und weiterentwickelt
[Musik]
wir machen diese erfahrungen mit unseren
sinnen unser bewusstsein unsere
selbsterkenntnis all diese eindrücke
sind in unserem gehirn gespeichert und
lassen diese gefühle der schönheit
aufkommen ob sich die schönheit
entlarven lässt als chemische reaktion
die sich in unserem gehirn abspielt nun
das wissen wir noch nicht aber es kann
sein dass mit dem zufall die erde ist
ein zufall
die menschheit ist ein zufall in ihrem
bild ich denke wir sind ein
bemerkenswerter zufall
wir sind eine konsequenz von molekülen
die das tun was moleküle tun
interagieren sich aneinander heften und
immer komplexere systeme bilden
ich will mir keine definition von leben
an
das ist schwierig doch eine definition
wäre dass wir selbst replizierende
molekulare maschinen sind deshalb
tauchen gewisse dinge auf und bringen
planeten oder moleküle hervor ich kenne
die antwort nicht aber die könnte mit
der idee eines multiversums
zusammenhängen also damit dass das
universum unheimlich groß ist und dass
es je nach standort im universum andere
physikalische gesetze gibt da gibt es
alle möglichkeiten es gibt stellen des
universums in denen es keine moleküle
und keine kräfte gibt und in diesem
weiten raum der möglichkeiten gibt es
regionen des universums die moleküle
entstehen lassen können die sich binden
und die vervielfältigen der strukturen
aufbauen können und diese wiederum
können sich zu formen von leben
entwickeln
es sind wunderbare fragen aber ich
entschuldige mich dass ich nicht alle
antworten habe kommen sie in tausend
jahren zurück und wir können ihnen
vielleicht weiterhelfen
leider haben diese molekularen gebilde
den tod in ihrer dns eingeprägt sonst
würde die evolution ja gar nicht
funktionieren
sie wäre bei den ersten geschäften die
ewig gelebt hätten stecken geblieben
die evolution braucht den tod um
weiterzukommen
durch selektion von besseren varianten
es gibt aber keinen physikalischen grund
dass wir nicht ewig leben könnten
jetzt haben sie wohin gesagt kommen sie
1000 jahre wieder sie haben wunderschöne
fragen ob ich habe keine antwort darauf
welche philosophischen fragen
interessieren denn sie ich finde all
diese fragen interessant
deshalb bin ich ja auch astrophysiker
geworden mein vater stellte die selben
fragen
er war förster und hatte nicht die
möglichkeit auf die universität zu gehen
aber er hat darüber nachgedacht woher
stammt unser planet wie hat das
universum begonnen
was sind schwarze löcher er ermutigte
mich zu studieren
insgesamt hat die wissenschaft einige
seiner fragen beantwortet leider gibt es
immer noch viele die wir noch nicht
beantworten können
sie haben schon auch diese
philosophische neugier auch wenn sie
noch keine antworten haben
es gibt ja auch noch eine andere
dimension in ihrem leben nämlich die
musik und ich wollte sie gerne fragen
wenn sie den sternenhimmel anschauen ist
denn das was sie für sich daraus ziehen
vielleicht auch eine inspirationsquelle
für ihre musik musik ist für mich eine
möglichkeit mein gehirn zu entspannen um
abzuschalten
rhythmische abläufe zu erzeugen zu denen
ich tanzen kann
das genieße ich entschuldigung einen
drive das ist ein tanz club sound den
ich gemacht habe
das video dazu hat die tochter meiner
schwester gemacht
[Musik]
gehen sie gerne council ja meist nur ein
oder zweimal im jahr zur entspannung
manchmal gehen wir auch in einen club
ich habe sie haben hier auch hier ihr
album nichts gebracht
eine cd herausgegeben haben ist es ein
hobby von ihnen was sie so jung da
betreiben und das richtig viel platz ein
so neben ihren ganzen berechnungen des
beginns des universums für mich ist es
ein hobby eine art zu entspannen
es ist schwierig mehr als ein zwei dinge
gleichzeitig zu machen
es gibt den alltags beruf das
tagesgeschäft des professors nach
getaner arbeit entspanne ich mich und
mache etwas anderes schreiben oder musik
machen um dieses album fertigzustellen
habe ich zwei jahre gebraucht ich gegen
jeden monat jeweils an einem sonntag ins
studio dieses vergnügen dieses von
project braucht zeit seinen von project
das macht in erster linie spaß aber sie
ziehen ja schon auch sachen sozusagen
aus der astrophysik in die musik rein
also es gibt einen song von ihnen da
haben sie irgendwie glaube ich versucht
big bang da irgendwie rein zu bringen
sie versuchen spielerisch die sachen
schon zu verbinden oder nun weltraum und
universum sind offensichtlich eine
leidenschaft von mir
es ist schön diese mit musik zu
verbinden einer meiner songs hat als
kick drum das geräusch einer
kollabierenden supernova wenn man große
ohren hätte könnte man dem tod eines fix
sterns zu hören wie sein eisenkern
innerhalb einer halben sekunde in sich
zusammenstürzt das gibt einen
großartigen kick drum für den song was
kann man wirklich berechnen wie das
klingst und dann bauen sie ist ein in
einen song ja man nimmt einfach einen
stern aus eisen von der größe unserer
sonne und berechnet die schallwellen die
entstehen wenn der eisenkern zu einem
schwarzen loch kollabiert
aber es gibt keine geräusche im ohr da
draußen oder gewisse geräusche gibt es
schon da doch einige moleküle vorhanden
sind
die schallwellen kommt von der
oberfläche her dann ist da die gashülle
welche die supernova umgibt wenn diese
explodiert man kann den schall hören der
sich durch das gas ausbreitet
es scheint ja das interesse für
astrophysik ansteckend zu sein
ihre frau zumindest haben sie damit
infiziert sie haben zusammen mit ihr
dieses buch hier geschrieben gibt es auf
der dunklen seite vom mond aliens da
geht es um kinder fragen die ihre frau
hat es illustriert mit mit zeichnungen
so in dieser art da sieht man wie sie
gemeinsam eigentlich ein interesse
teilen ihr vater ein geschäft eröffnet
da kann man sachen kaufen aus hobby
astronomen was für hobby-astronomen wir
brauchen aber auch irgendwelche spiele
die zu tun haben mit astronomie ist es
wirklich so etwas was sie auch gemeinsam
teilen mit ihr wie sie in ihrer familie
nun wir dachten menschen werden durch
den weltraum inspiriert darum haben wir
letztes jahr einen kosmischen concept
store eröffnet das einzige ladengeschäft
das wir kennen welches weltraum artikel
verkauft das können schmuck oder socken
sein was auch immer es gibt eine reihe
schöner dinge die leute lieben den
weltraum
meine frau teilt dieses interesse auch
wir haben den text zusammen geschrieben
und sie hat ihn auch illustriert machen
wir einen schnitt noch mal zurück sie
haben wohin ein stichwort erwähnt sie
haben gesagt eigentlich könnten wir uns
selbst beschreiben als molekulare
maschinen die sich reproduzieren können
das ist eigentlich ungefähr das
menschenbild das materialisten oder
physikalischen haben das ist das
menschenbild was in den
naturwissenschaften letztendlich ein
vorherrscht man kann natürlich sagen das
ist ein bisschen frustrierend wenn ich
an mich selber banker an die
subjektivität gehen wir empfinden unser
bewusstsein dann denkt man doch sind wir
irgendwie mehr also das würde ja
dass wir irgendwie ich weiß nicht so was
sehen wir ein neuronaler juckreiz und
nicht mehr also alles was wir empfinden
ist eben nur biochemisch ist es wie sie
befriedigend und genug ich bin kein
neurowissenschaftler aber ich hoffe dass
sich jedes sichtbare phänomen um mich
herum im universum irgendwie
quantifizieren und es durch die
bekannten kräfte der natur erklären kann
das ist mir lieber als mich auf etwas
völlig unbekanntes zu berufen dass ich
nicht beschreiben kann
wenn ich neurowissenschaftler wäre würde
ich um unser bewusstsein zu verstehen
von bekanntem ausgehen
ich würde mich nicht auf etwas anderes
berufen wenn es etwas anderes gibt dann
können wir das erforschen
ich kenne die antwort nicht meine
tochter ist jetzt 17 und will in die
schweiz kommen um ihr
neurowissenschaften zu studieren
ich habe sie für dieses gebiet
begeistern können sie wird hoffentlich
mithelfen diese frage in der zukunft zu
beantworten
ich denke man nur mit all diesen
theorien die mir eigentlich schon ein
leuchten ist es trotzdem ein bisschen so
als würde ich selber zum alien in dieser
welt weil ich irgendwie mich nicht mehr
zurecht finde in meiner eigenen denkwelt
weil ich den eindruck habe wenn ich mir
wirklich vorstellen dass das alles nur
irgendwie neuronale prozesse sind die
mit dem kopf klären dann deckt sich das
ja nicht mit meinem empfinden ich habe
das gefühl das steckt an ich darin
da gibt es einen geist da gibt es ein
bewusstsein und das hat auch extrem
irritieren dass sich das überhaupt gar
nicht erklären zu können ja vielleicht
ist es die angst vor unserer demut die
angst davor dass wir nur moleküle sind
eine folge molekulare interaktionen wenn
sie unser bewusstsein verstehen als
erkenntnis unserer welt und von uns
selbst dann ist dieses problem
vergleichbar mit dem verstehen des
urknalls der entstehung unseres
universums
bei diesen beiden fragen sind wir erst
am anfang und beginnen erst an der
oberfläche zu kratzen und zu verstehen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wissen wir über
den urknall und über unser bewusstsein
nur so viel wir wissen dass wir
weitergekommen sind dass wir das
universum bis zurück zu einer bestimmten
zeit verstehen und wir verstehen dass
unser bewusstsein irgendwie mit einem
neuronalen netz zusammenhängt und mit
den informationen die darin fließen
aber es ist auch ein schrecklich
komplizierter prozess
ich denke die neurowissenschaften machen
große fortschritte
aber ich weiß nicht ob sie die antworten
der psychologen vollständig befriedigend
das sind wahrscheinlich auch die ganz
schwierigen frage man sagt ja auch das
mind body problem dass leib seele
problem ist eigentlich in der
philosophie immer noch eines der
schwierigsten es ist ungelöst und die
philosophen streiten sich wie man dieses
problem lösen kann
und kürzlich hat ein philosoph thomas
nagel ein buch geschrieben in dem er
gesagt hat alle die versuche zu erklären
wie das universum entstanden ist müssten
doch irgendwie eine idee auch davon
geben die so etwas wie geist in diese
welt gekommen ist oder in dieses
universum gekommen ist das müsste
sozusagen mit gedacht gewesen sein vom
ersten moment an und deswegen glaubt er
auch braucht es noch eine idee mehr
nicht nur naturwissenschaften nicht nur
reinen materialismus gibt es da schon
irgendwelche fortschritte oder
irgendwelche ideen eines astrophysikers
wie der geist in die welt gekommen ist
ich würde nicht sagen dass die
astrophysik meine kollegen und ich sind
zwar an diesem thema interessiert aber
ich denke nicht dass wir in einem
forschungs kontext zu diesem thema etwas
zu sagen haben
ich glaube nicht dass meine disziplin
dabei helfen kann
diese probleme sind zu groß sie hängen
nicht miteinander zusammen
außer in dem sinn dass die entstehung
der planeten und galaxien also dass die
vielen geräusche die
energie die partikel irgendwie geordnet
worden sind und etwas struktur in die
komplexität gebracht wird
dasselbe gilt für die entstehung des
gehirns ein system das sich langsam von
einem ungeordneten systemen einem haufen
atome und moleküle hin zur komplexität
und ordnung entwickelt hat dass es heute
ist der ursprung der komplexität könnte
also das gemeinsame das verbindende
thema sein
und wenn es diese möglichkeit gibt
dieser entwicklung die von statten geht
dann stellt sich natürlich auch die
frage sind eigentlich die einzigen die
so entwickelt sind zu intelligent
geworden sind sind wir die einzigen die
irgendwo hier am leben sind und da sagen
sie nein ich kann sie trösten es gibt
eine ganz große wahrscheinlichkeit dass
es irgendwo da draußen noch anderes
leben gibt wie groß ist diese
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es da irgendwo
noch leben gibt okay gut das wird die
frage des tages
wir kehren wir zum thema gehirn zurück
auf unserem planeten gibt es mindestens
eine million verschiedener spezies die
sich unabhängig in mannigfaltiger weise
entwickelt haben mit gehirnen
wir haben unser gehirn in den letzten
paar hunderttausend jahren entwickelt
und sind zu dem geworden was wir sind
elefanten sind gewiss klug und haben
gehirne die so groß sind wie unsere ein
octopus hingegen hat ein komplett
anderes neuronales system aber er ist
ein sehr intelligentes problem lösen das
geschäftsleben ist intelligenz und nicht
nur auf den menschen beschränkt und nun
fragen wir uns was liegt da draußen
inmitten der sterne gibt es
außerirdisches leben und wie könnte
dieses aussehen
diesbezüglich hat die astronomie in
jüngster zeit große fortschritte gemacht
durch die entdeckung dass die meisten
sterne am nachthimmel ihre eigenen
planeten haben und die sie umkreisen
stellen sie sich beim betrachten des
sternenhimmels vor jeder einzelne stern
hat eigene planeten die in umkreisen
da es allein in unserer galaxie
milliarden von sternen gibt ist die
möglichkeit gegeben das leben unabhängig
von unserer erde entstanden ist
angesichts der verschiedenartigkeit und
der unglaublichen evolution welche auf
unserem planeten stattgefunden hat von
mikroben bis zu elefanten sehe ich nicht
ein weshalb dies nicht auch in anderen
welten stattgefunden haben kann
sie möchten sich nicht wirklich
festlegen
wir können es nicht
dieses thema ist ein wenig ärgerlich
schauen sie in der wissenschaftlichen
literatur gibt es dutzende abhandlungen
die sagen leben ist extrem
unwahrscheinlich oder sehr
wahrscheinlich
sie alle sind falsch denn wir wissen
nicht wie leben begonnen hat also können
wir nicht anders wo nach der
wahrscheinlichkeit von leben suchen
solange wir nicht wissen wie es begonnen
hat ich werde mich also nicht über die
wahrscheinlichkeit äußern
doch was ich mit einem guten gefühl
sagen kann ist dass es da draußen
milliarden von planeten wie unsere erde
gibt
ich glaube nicht dass unser planet und
unser stern einzigartig sind und warum
sollte dein leben eine besonderheit
unseres planeten sein sich ausland
interessiert die dümmsten fragen oder
die größten fragen beantworten zu
kriegen sie leisten nicht dauernd darauf
hin dass man darüber noch nicht so viel
weiß was ich denn für sie aus professor
für astrophysik ein guter tag vor dem
computer gibt es diesen moment wo sie
merken jetzt habe ich herausgefunden
jetzt ist wirklich die gleichung richtig
gibt es diese momente noch die gibt es
noch
es ist ein großartiges gefühl wenn sie
ein neues phänomen entdeckt haben und
sie es als erster mensch sehen
das ist schon etwas besonderes es
geschieht allerdings nicht regelmäßig
wissenschaft funktioniert nicht so
üblicherweise entwickelt sich die
wissenschaft stufenweise schritt für
schritt entdeckungen sind heutzutage
meist das ergebnis vieler
wissenschaftler die zusammenarbeiten und
auf den resultaten anderer
wissenschaftler aufbauen
ab und zu kommt man zu einer
persönlichen einsicht und das ist dann
ein großartiges gefühl wenn wir diesen
menschen uns vorstellen aus molekulare
maschine wenn ich bei diesem ausdruck
bleiben darf kann ich da tue ja
eigentlich auch nichts anderes wie das
herunterfahren eines betriebssystems
langsam werden die moleküle sich
abkühlen und aufhören zu funktionieren
und dann ist irgendwann wenn sie feuer
so würden sie wahrscheinlich den tod
auch beschreiben sie sagen in ihrem buch
elefanten im all
dass sie nicht so oft über den tod
nachdenken und sagen leider denken sie
nicht oft über den tod nach warum leider
wie sie gesagt haben wenn wir sterben
schaltet sich unsere molekulare maschine
aus und unser gehirn zerfällt im boden
und wird wieder rezitiert das ist die
zukunft vieler generation von leben
sie nehmen unsere kohlenstoff atome in
ihre körper auf unsere atome sind durch
viele generationen von lebenden
organismen gegangen
wir sind wahrscheinlich das ergebnis
zehntausender spezies die gestorben sind
und deren moleküle wiederverwertet und
zu unseren geworden sind ja ich denke
wenn wir sterben dann war es das
das leben ist vorbei also genießen sie
ihre zeit auf dieser welt solange wir da
sind und machen sie das beste daraus
das ist ein motiv sie sagen möglich das
leben ausschöpfen lässt einfach so schön
ist und weil der tod sowieso kommt genau
was ich versuche mein leben zu genießen
und das beste daraus zu machen
deshalb mag ich es populäre bücher zu
schreiben und zu erklären was wir in der
wissenschaft tun und dieses wunder des
universums und des lebens weiterzugeben
wenn ich versuche jede stunde mit etwas
nützlichem zu füllen
nur ab und zu setze ich mich hin und
spiele ein computerspiel also auch ein
bisschen ablenkung ist was schönes
wir haben noch einmal hans dieter müller
gefragt was er sich über den tod so
denken warum er denkt es braucht auch in
diesem tod irgendwie mehr als nur das
herunterfahren des systems ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass ein leben was so
viel freude und auch schmerz beinhaltet
hat was für denjenigen der es erlebt
fundamental wichtig ist dass das einfach
ins nichts vergeht vor allen dingen
kommt es mir unwahrscheinlich vor dass
es keine gerechtigkeit für die opfer der
geschichte gibt also auch wenn es kein
leben nach dem tode gibt wenn es keinen
gott gibt dann sind die opfer für ewige
opfer es gibt keine gerechtigkeit für
sie und die sechs millionen juden die
hitler umgebracht haben haben dasselbe
schicksal wie der der sich erschossen
hat das ist schwer verdaulich als horte
deutscher es ist schwer verdaulich ende
der durchsage
die idee der gerechtigkeit macht gar
keinen sinn für sie für mich nicht
es ist schwierig das zu akzeptieren oder
zu begreifen wir leben
und dann sind wir tot unsere existenz
ist in einem gewissen sinne
bedeutungslos wo wir doch unserem leben
sinn geben wollen
es war ein versuch unserem leben einen
sinn zu geben und wir machen damit
trotzdem weiter ich würde die frage
umdrehen und sie so stellen wo war denn
das alles während des urknalls als es
kein leben und keine sterne gab
das leben kam erst milliarden von jahren
nach der entstehung unseres universums
auf und alles leben wird enden wenn in
der zukunft die sterne ausbrennen
wo wird das leben dann hingehen das
universum bei dunkel seien in ferner
zukunft
es wird keinen weg geben leben zu
erhalten wir wissen ja dass es im
früheren universum kein leben gegeben
hat und es wird keine möglichkeit für
ewiges leben geben
das leben kann nur während einer kurzen
zeit in diesem universum auftauchen
wir müssen dem leben die bedeutung geben
die wir können ich kann nicht mehr sinn
hinein geben als im moment möglich ist
wahr wir sind hier lasst es uns genießen
haben sie ja ganz richtig man kann
trotzdem seinem leben einen sinn geben
also in der philosophie unterscheidet
man ja zwischen dem sinn der von außen
kommt dass er die idee gott gibt diesem
leben einen sinn und der idee wir selber
sind es die unserem leben sinn verleihen
im sinne von wir haben ein sinnvolles
leben geführt
da frage ich mich in einem
naturwissenschaftlichen bild woher kommt
dieser sinn wenn ihr ihn aus uns
schöpfen also denken sie beispielsweise
kann ja nur die liebe ist etwas was
unserem leben sinn gibt oder die
betrachtung der natur richtig ich denke
die religion kann jemanden der das
braucht diesen sinn geben
ich bin nie religiös gewesen sondern
habe im leben einen sinn meine moral
auch ohne religion gefunden
ich denke ich bin ein guter mensch ohne
irgendwie religiös beeinflusst worden zu
sein
ich bin vegetarier und habe nie in
meinem leben ein tier gegessen
ich weiß nicht mal wie fleisch schmeckt
dieses prinzip stammt aus der
wissenschaft ich finde es wunderbar am
leben zu sein
ich würde das leben eines anderen tieres
nicht beenden wollen
ich würde andere tiere auch nicht
grausam behandeln bloß weil ich sie
essen will
aus diesem grund esse ich kein tier
leben ist wertvoll
doch diese moral habe ich nicht von der
religion sondern aus der sorge um die
welt um mich herum
von gleichgesinnten vom einfluss meines
vaters und von der wissenschaft dass das
ein prinzip ist dass sie aus der
wissenschaft haben im grunde genommen
tiere essen tiere viele sagen ja gerade
gerade naturwissenschaftlich gesehen
sind die werte die wir haben eigentlich
überhaupt nichts da brauchen wir
irgendwie mehr irgendeine idee einer
transzendenz oder sollte ich würde den
begriff der wissenschaft nicht so eng
sehen eher so wie ich es vorher
beschrieben habe das leben beginnt und
endet leben kann in unserem universum
nur kurze zeit existieren deshalb ist es
so besonders und großartig lassen wir
das leben an sich selbst erfreuen
aber sie haben keinen sozusagen
moralischen imperativ dass sie sagen
würden es ist falsch fleisch zu essen
oder es ist falsch einander zu quälen
doch aber ich würde niemandem einen
vegetarismus aufdrängen
ich würde nur mit gutem beispiel voran
gehen und zeigen dass ich ein leben lang
vegetarier und dennoch gesund und
halbwegs intelligent sein kann
ich würde meine haltung anderen niemals
aufzwingen
in unserem universum gibt es kein
richtig oder falsch wenn sie es
naturwissenschaftlich betrachten wir
erschaffen unser richtig und falsch
selber durch unser kollektives verhalten
um als spezies zu profitieren
nur so weit kann man eigentlich gehen
was ist wenn wir noch darüber sprechen
ob es da draußen noch anderes leben gibt
wenn eines tages die aliens hier
ankommen das ist ein beliebtes motiv der
science-fiction-literatur wir haben
viele bilder im kopf wie diese aliens
aussehen kann ich habe vier ausgesucht
was würden sie sagen gibt es da in
naturwissenschaftlich gesehen
irgendwelche indizien dass es eher wie
et aussieht oder er wie so eine hr giger
eine skulptur unten rechts oder
ja vielleicht ja ne solche viel plastik
die hollywood darstellung von
außerirdischen leben ist oft sehr
voreingenommen
meistens sind es unförmige und land
niedrige kreaturen doch wir haben nur
erfahrungen mit dem leben auf erden
wir haben keine ahnung wie fremdes leben
aussehen könnte und wenn es so weit käme
was würden wir damit anfangen
dazu gibt es ein passendes zitat von
wittgenstein er schrieb eine sprache
vorstellen heißt sich eine lebensform
vorstellen
das zeigt die komplexität auf wenn man
versucht mit fremdem leben zu
kommunizieren sprache ist äußerst
kompliziert
sie besteht aus wortfolgen betonungen
und so weiter würden wir eine botschaft
von fremdem leben von einem anderen
stern empfangen hätten den gewissen
damit zu kämpfen sie zu verstehen
wir würden verschlüsselungs analytiker
und code knacker brauchen um eine alien
sprache zu verstehen was sie sagen sind
sie ein bisschen lächerlich dass man
1977 ja so eine art galaktische
flaschenpost auf den weg gebracht hat
midway wann hat man eine golden record
hat man auf den weg gebracht und darauf
hat man ganz viele dinge auf gespielt
die von dem gedenken das für die
menschheit unglaublich wichtig gewesen
da ist musik drauf da sind aber auch
vogelstimmen drauf naturgeräusche und so
weiter die allgemeine erklärung der
menschenrechte ist es ein bisschen
lächerlich diese idee es ist eine schöne
idee
das symbolisiert das was wir bis zu
jener zeit erreicht hatten
es war uns gelungen ein raumfahrzeug
über unser sonnensystem hinaus zu
schicken
es war ein letztes symbol natürlich hat
man nicht erwartet dass es aliens
abfangen würden dieses ding würde durch
den kalten dunklen weltraumreisen und
wohl nie gefunden werden
man hat gar nicht das war das ziel ist
es irgendwann
nicht das wissenschaftliche ziel der
voyager war das äußere sonnensystem zu
verstehen dass die goldene daten platte
gefunden würde stand nicht im
vordergrund der mission
aber es war ein schöner kleiner
fingerzeig von kreissägen stephen
hawking den ja sehr viele leute kennen
berühmte air astrophysiker der sagt in
letzter zeit wir müssen uns beeilen weil
wir jetzt hier sehr ungemütlich schon in
100 jahren sagte neuerdings wird die
erde unbewohnbar sein
teilen sie diese einschätzung das ist
einer der pessimistischen gesichtspunkte
es gibt die möglichkeit dass alles
bergab geht
es sieht manchmal nicht so gut aus wenn
man den zustand unseres planeten
betrachtet die umweltverschmutzung die
globale erwärmung
dann gibt es auch die idee von der
technologischen singularität welche in
100 jahren so weit fortgeschritten sein
wird das künstliche intelligenz die
robotik maschinen weit intelligenter
sein werden als der mensch und diese
würden alles übernehmen und wir würden
alle durch roboter getötet es gibt viele
szenarien für den untergang unseres
planeten
wir müssen über diese nachdenken und
vorsichtig sein wenn wir roboter bauen
müssen wir gut verstehen was wir tun das
kann helfen diesen prozess gefahrlos zu
machen
eine möglichkeit ist ja auch
auszuweichen also stephen hawking
empfiehlt das dass wir uns mal genauer
angucken es wurde ja vor kurzem kentaur
ib entdeckt wir könnten dahin reisen
allenfalls wir haben hier einen bild
vorbereitet das ist sozusagen auch aus
unserer nachbargalaxien wie haben sie
vorhin ja schon erwähnt mit dem zucker
beispiel die 5 km die wir waren dann
müssen bis wir da sind
halten sie das wirklich für möglich dass
man die einst auf seinem planeten leben
könnte das die menschen dahin fliegen
und dort sich niederlassen
das ist der grund weshalb ich da draußen
geschrieben habe eine geschichte die
zeigt wie leben da draußen inmitten der
sterne und solcher welten aussehen
könnte dieser proxima centauri b ist ein
paar kilometer entfernt von hier im
schnellsten heutigen raumschiff wird es
rund hunderttausend jahre dauern wird
hinzukommen
aber wir haben die technik und das
verständnis diese reise während eines
menschenlebens zu machen was wir nicht
haben ist die weltweite organisation
oder den wunsch diese reise zu
unternehmen
die meisten ressourcen unseres planeten
die finanzen das geld das man braucht um
ein raumschiff dorthin zu schicken wird
für kriege ausgegeben
ja gewiss wenn ein großteil unseres
bruttosozialproduktes für
massenvernichtungswaffen eingesetzt wird
und nur ein bruchteil eines prozents in
die weltraumfahrt und die
weltraumforschung fließt so stellt das
für mich ein großes missverhältnis dar
fakt ist dass wir geld für waffen
verschwenden
dieses geld könnten wir für die
wissenschaft brauchen mit einem
bruchteil davon könnten wir ein
raumschiff nach alpha centauri schicken
es ist sehr interessant für mich das so
zu hören weil ich meistens einen anderen
vergleich höhere nämlich den vergleich
mit dem geld das wir investieren
beispielsweise um malaria auszurotten
oder um die welt armut zu beseitigen und
dann wird oft gesagt gegeben so viel aus
für die raumfahrt um so wenig um das
leiden auf unserem planeten zu
beseitigen
sie machen jetzt einen ganz anderen
vergleich nun die investition in die
wissenschaft haben uns so weit gebracht
wie wir heute sind in der globalen
technik gestützten welt
das hat flugzeuge zum fliegen gebracht
das hat uns die fortschrittliche medizin
gebracht investment die investitionen in
die wissenschaft erfolgen zufällig denn
man kann nicht voraussagen welchen
nutzen man aus einer wissenschaftlichen
erforschung haben wird das internet zum
beispiel war nur ein nebenprodukt von
teilchenphysiker am 10
es wurde nicht direkt finanziert es war
nur ein ableger dasselbe gilt für die
raumforschung sie hat zu vielen
fortschritten geführt zb in der
medizinischen bildgebung das ist nur ein
gebiet ich sage ja nicht dass man das
ganze militärbudget in den weltraum
stecken solle einen kleinen teil davon
jedoch schon
das ermöglicht neue entwicklungen und
fortschritte herr moore nische sagte
einmal in ihren einem abgelegenen winkel
des aus gegossenen weltalls gab es
einmal einen gestirn auf dem kluge
tierchen das verstehen erkennen erfanden
ich glaube wir stehen noch ziemlich am
anfang des erkennens wenn ich ihnen
zuhöre
aber wir haben offenbar auch noch ein
bisschen zeit packen wir es an ich bin
gespannt was sie noch alles raus gehen
und ich danke ihnen sehr dass sie bei
uns zu besuch waren dankeschön
danke dass sie mich eingeladen haben
nächste woche spricht mein kollege ist
wasser hat mit der ungarische
philosophin agnes heller
sie hat das jüdin den holocaust und
später den stalin erstens hautnah
miterlebt heute erhebt die 88 jährige
ihre stimme gegen die ungarische
regierung und plädiert für mehr freiheit
und jetzt gleich nehmen wir sie mit auf
streifzüge durch die deutsche und
belgische kinogeschichte von der
studienzeit bis zu tun erdmann von den
dateien brüdern bis zu tim und struppi
zeit sich zurückzulehnen also und den
feiertag zu genießen
tun sie es und bis bald
[Musik]